I am NOT your dad I am an electric man
superheroes are some of the most
prevalent and numerous icons in fiction
right now across a whole slew of media
with original characters created for
comics movies novels and real life too I
guess but there's a shockingly slim
amount of original superheroes created
for the world of gaming there's carnage
if he was a hot topic employee and then
there's the infamous Cole MacGrath
seeing is how I've made it a point to
review every superhero related game in
existence at one point or another I
think it's only fitting that we give ol
Cole the whole bowl to attain our goal
this review was requested for the $100
tier on my patreon by Jeremy Cote and I
just want to give a quick shout out to
him and his bride-to-be Mary Ann well I
wish you guys a happy marriage that goes
untainted by the woes of editorial
mandated demon retcons and guilt-based
time travel does anyone care about that
anymore
this games ten years old and it was to
my understanding it was pretty well
regarded so I think everyone knows that
plot twists by now Wow
it's hard to believe this is ten years
old actually I felt like I just played
this yesterday except I was shorter and
the world wasn't as terrifying and
movies had more variety and games came
in one single package instead of having
the content parsed out over the course
of several months for additional money
and action figures had better sculpting
and more importance of articulation
actually I can believe this was a decade
ago things are pretty different now
especially standards and gaming so let's
see how one of my all-time favorite
games holds up ten years later anyhoo
this game starts out with one of the
coolest transitions from main menu to
gameplay ever by having you start out as
the poor millennial schmuck that was
unfortunate enough to wake up at Ground
Zero of this massive gas blow him
our main character Cole waddles his
crusty voice out of the crater and then
into a flash forward explaining that he
was a bike messenger who mistakenly
activated a bomb that ripped a hole in
not New York but also gave him
superpowers by draining the life force
of everyone caught in the blast zone now
he can basically do everything electro
can just short of becoming a living
lightning bolt the consequence though is
that crime and sickness run rampant now
after his explosive debut and the city
from superhero movie is now under
government quarantine meaning gangs with
various unique gimmicks and powers of
their own start cropping up to take
charge that just means is up to our
gravelly voiced electrical protagonists
his comic relief's sidekick and his
tired love interest to stop them and
make the city safe again as well as
figure out who is behind the super power
bomb in the first place
don't say it don't say it don't say it
don't say it
let's talk about the gameplay I'd say
for 2009 it wasn't anything
revolutionary but damn is this game feel
solidly built they weren't exactly
reinventing the wheel for some of these
mechanics you know being that some of
them were recycled from the developers
last game Sly Cooper or some of them are
just third-person shooter gameplay
reskin to take out the shooting part but
at the same time you feel really
powerful with the way you can zap away
in hordes of enemies using rifles and
rocket launchers you don't need any of
that lame [ __ ] guns are for nerds also
this character is incapable of using
them the dialogue early in the game
makes it a point to establish that
Cole's new powers make him unable to use
vehicles or firearms the second you
judge that the electricity in your hands
cooks off the Gunpowder and the whole
thing goes Kabam yeah not some genius
invents a car that doesn't explode when
I sit in it so you have a pretty solid
excuse for why you're having to climb
and run everywhere and even though
traversal is pretty tedious early in the
game you slowly unlock more methods of
getting around quickly until you don't
even think about it anymore like this
sick rail grind on power lines like
static shock and legally distinct yet
heavily derivative black lightning
equivalent I think Cole and Max Dillon
are the only white guys with electrical
power
okay just Coleman this is one of the few
games that also gives you enough fun
stuff to do in the open world that I
actually got 100% completion for all the
district activities they do a decent job
of balancing odd jobs like finding
collectables with various combat
challenges and I think the gameplay for
both is just so fun that I don't even
mind it
[Music]
so the combat isn't anything
groundbreaking but they managed to fit a
crazy amount of mechanics and powers
into your button scheme there's like six
ways to blow people up and when you're I
add juice you just go to any electrical
thing in the area to recharge it's also
a huge plus that you can fire lightning
out of your hands as fast as you can hit
the button look at this do things that
get me so hooked on this game or the
amount of variety and locations and
little challenges thrown in here and
there sometimes you're fighting bad guys
in a spooky tunnel filled with black goo
that poisons your mind or you're
climbing a massive Tower made of garbage
and fighting a bunch of Klansmen in
trash bags or you're riding an
electrified bus or fighting in an
abandoned prison that's built like a
castle or geez there's a lot of these
but on top of that like any good
superhero character Cole has his
weaknesses like throat lozenges and
having to fight when there's no good
source of electricity nearby to drain
from or being surrounded by water that
kills him on contact wait so he can't
touch water
how does he shower can he hydrate does
he have a hard time going to the
bathroom I have so many questions maybe
that's why his voice sounds so mangled
dude can't drink some water to clear it
out he sounds like he's gargling
thumbtacks I know the prototype
comparisons have been done to death but
I think between the two of them the
thing that sticks out most to me is how
both of the characters are dressed kind
of like a douchey edge lord except in
Cole's case you have the option to
choose not to be a bad guy and overcome
that exterior well as Alex Mercer is
still a douchey edge lord it's pretty
apparent what era of gaming this was
released in because it has a really
half-baked choice system that plagued a
lot of things coming out back then
spider-man web of Shadows army of two
the 40th day Saints Row 3 BioShock
Infinite kinda all games that were
pretty linear in terms of story where
your choices had very little actual
effects save for slightly different
cutscenes or unlocking an extra piece of
gear usually punctuated by a choice for
the ending that would ultimately make
such a huge point of divergence that any
sequel would just say the more
reasonable one is canon I think
infallible here has the same problem
that all of these had and that these
choices feel tacked on and meaningless
characters still react to you pretty
much the same way and scene
that matter nothing has any real long
reaching consequences for later entries
in the series and the best powers are
locked behind pure evil or pure good
paths so forces you to pick one or the
other because you can't do certain
things if you pick a more neutral run so
it really just comes down to which color
of lightning you like more blue makes
more sense so I guess I'll be a morally
righteous pushover really this game
would have felt pretty much the same if
that system wasn't included
I think judging by the sequels and how
hellaciously silly the player characters
get with evil choices the idea just
hasn't aged well if they ever get around
to an infamous for I don't think I'd
miss this aspect of the franchise
[Music]
don't get me wrong I still think choices
and video games are important when it
matters so you know something like Mass
Effect or twenty percent of The Walking
Dead is a more positive example of that
being implemented as long as we're on
the topic of negatives about this game
let's talk about the aesthetic and I
don't mean the graphics because those
are about serviceable for the time sure
the characters look a little stilted and
the facial animations could use some
work but otherwise it's fine what really
bugs me is just how ugly this game is
everything looks kind of disgusting like
this is one of the more unpleasant
looking games I can recall from recent
memory pretty much everything is either
covered in dust trash black slime mud or
some strange fluid that's a combination
of all of that the colors are so muted
and dull for a character that shoots
lightning which you think would be an
opening to make it have some really
bright and poppy neon colors but now the
aesthetic for the gameplay is
appropriate given the story they want to
tell since the city is in a state of
crisis it looks war-torn gross and
dangerous sure but sometimes it gets a
little hard to look at for hours and
hours on end and you'd like a break from
the glass shard filled mud being rubbed
in your eyes even fallout changed up the
aesthetic in certain areas just to give
you a break
save for the main menu screen we never
really get to see the city before it's a
Detroit hole so we can't exactly tell
how far it's fallen I think it would
have been more effective to see a
flashback of the city pretty explosion
or maybe just play a little bit prior to
Cole opening the bomb so we can get a
sense of progression for all we know
empire city has always looked like this
the gangs are just more active now maybe
I'm splitting hairs and that's a really
stupid complaint but it's something that
jumped out at me while replaying this
maybe as a kid I was more used to it
because a lot of games back then just
look like ugly brown and gray post
apocalypses even the spider-man games at
the time weren't very colorful at least
in this one they sometimes break up the
monotony of the visuals with these
motion comic style cutscenes that have
this kind of spray painted graffiti look
like runny splatter e ink all over the
place and very few colors with a grainy
texture to everything like it's all
painted on a brick wall I think this art
style is gritty like the gameplay but
stylized enough to also be visually
interesting instead of repugnant but the
cynic in me is still looking at them and
thinking boy they sure saved a lot of
money on animating
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ten years later and one of the things
that still stuck with me the most was
how I hated the final morality choice
but also loved the ending of this game
so the villain who set all this stuff up
you know the guy running an evil
organization for decades that built the
superpower bomb
guiding you around to more moral
dilemmas and occasionally kicking your
ass he makes you make a choice between
saving 10 doctors or Cole's girlfriend
who kind of tolerates him again by this
point in the game whether you choose
true love or the needs of the many she
still dies I remember as a kid being
insanely frustrated when I picked the
group of doctors and got this death
scene and think to look up the other
option then because I was like 10 years
old so I rolled it back to an older save
file played like 40 minutes of the game
over again get back to this and chose
her instead only to get the same scene
your choice doesn't matter this was the
first time I ever experienced that in a
game so out of frustration from messing
up my hero run I went back again to get
the blue color version of the scene and
thinking I just couldn't trust this game
anymore it killed a lot of my hype for
the final hour of the game but then the
final boss made up for it and brought it
all back this bad guy Kesler has every
power you have plus all the other ones
you've seen in this game thus far from
the other enemies plus some new [ __ ] you
haven't seen any characters new and
reusing the blast zone as the final boss
arena was really cool as soon as this
fight started my hype levels rose again
because I had a bit of a hunch about the
ending that turned out to be true the
final boss is actually the player
character from the future my mind was
blown as a kid and I was so stoked that
I guessed it right based on all the
hints see old Cola here came from an
alternate future where he was a huge
coward who decided not to fight a super
villain that blew up the world and
killed his family so he went back in
time to train his younger self to be
less of a [ __ ] and make him strong
enough physically and emotionally to
fight that villain when it finally came
around and saved the world so in a sense
he's kind of still the good guy despite
being the bad guy I had never seen a
plot twist in a story like this up to
this point except for Benton race
against time
so this ending really won me back over
then BioShock Infinite ripped out
three years later and I audibly booed at
the screen it's not a perfect game by
any means because not every game can be
simpsons hit and run but it's got a lot
to talk about the gameplay isn't
anything innovative but it's very solid
and fun even to this day you really feel
like infamous the story is mostly
underwhelming but really pulls out all
the stops at the end overall I think I
found myself very attached to the
characters even though Zeke is basically
just Roman but like from Texas the
visual elements of it and a few of the
lame little gimmicks and signs of the
time haven't exactly aged well but they
don't hold the good parts back enough to
say it aged poorly overall the good
outshines the bad and I don't regret
replaying this at all I can even see
myself coming back to it again sometime
I don't say it's a groundbreaking
game-changer that define the genre nor
is it a mess beyond repair
nor will I say it's a beautiful love
letter to some oddly specific genre it's
simply just a solid game that's worth
playing if you like open-world superhero
junk and men with voices like sandpaper
just a quick reminder before you go that
I post my videos a day early on patreon
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
content and patron exclusive videos
please consider becoming a patron it
really helps me out if you want a more
short-term way to support the channel
you can check out my merch and links in
the description we have t-shirts phone
cases posters mugs pillows baby onesies
and so much more see you next time
[Music]
[Music]